[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
before we get started i just wanted to
say a big thank you to everyone
for helping us reach 200 000 subscribers
this is a massive milestone and we
couldn't have done it without you
in this video we're going to be
discussing lord voldemort
the fabled basilisk that resides within
the chamber of secrets
and the effects of its menacing glare
we're first introduced to the basilisk
which was the horrific creation of
hogwarts founder salazar slytherin
in the chamber of secrets the basilisk
was placed inside of a secret chamber in
the school
because salazar disagreed with the other
founders in their philosophy that
muggleborn should be allowed to attend
the school
salazar was a strong advocate of blood
purity and felt that
only pure blood witches and wizards were
worthy of attending the school
unable to influence the way that the
other founders felt salazar created
the basilisk in a last-ditch effort to
effectively rid the school
of muggleborns knowing that he wouldn't
live forever
salazar put magic in place to ensure
that whoever was his rightful heir
would be able to control the creature
any descendant of salazars
would be able to communicate with the
giant creature via parcel tongue
the language of snakes those who are
able to speak parcel tongue
are known as parcel mounts and voldemort
was widely known to possess
this ability as harry potter had a piece
of voldemort's soul fragment inside of
him
he also possessed this ability which is
why he was able to understand the
basilisk
speaking however just because harry was
a pastor mouth
it did not mean that he was able to
control the basilisk in any capacity
that responsibility was left with the
rightful heir of slytherin alone
tom middle when harry enters the chamber
of secrets
he's almost immediately faced with the
mythical creature
and harry who was aware of the basilisks
capabilities
knew that he had to be very careful the
basilisk
you see possesses the ability to kill
people with its gaze alone
if you stare directly into the basilisks
eyes you are sure to die
and if you look at it indirectly i.e the
reflection
you'll be petrified which is what
happened to so many students at hogwarts
during the 1992 school year harry
who is unaware of how to engage an
opponent that he can't even look at
simply runs away from the basilisk with
no real plan in mind
however fortunately for harry fawkes
saves the day
by clawing the basilisks eyes out which
gives harry a fighting
chance knowing that the basilisk is
blind
and can no longer use its killer gaze
gives harry just enough confidence
to fight back however one thing that i
have always wondered is
would the basilisks killing gays have
the same effect
on its master tom riddle is voldemort
invulnerable to the effects of the
basilisks gaze
in the chamber of secrets film
adaptation we see tom riddle stare
directly into the eyes of the basilisk
when it's summoned so i'm going to need
some kind of explanation
my first thought is that because tom
riddle was just a memory
the basilisk would simply not have the
same sort of effect on him
i was less than spirits less than the
meanest ghost
but still i was alive tom riddle was not
a real
corporeal being he was something else
altogether
and staring directly into the basilisks
eyes may not have been something
that the original young tom riddle would
have been able to do
however the issue with this theory is of
course the fact there's no way that tom
riddle
would be able to know how his later form
would react
to the basilisk's gaze so why would he
stare at it
so confidently why would he make a
reckless mistake like that
without understanding the potential
consequences my strongest theory
for why tom riddle was able to stare at
the basilisk
is that the basilisk can simply decide
who it kills with its stare
all of the basilisks victims were people
that tom riddle
the basilisks controller would have
wanted dead
and there's no canon evidence to support
that the basilisk
would independently want these people
dead for this reason
i'm of the opinion that the basilisks
stare is only
activated when it has intent to kill
particularly
when it is ordered to do so what do you
guys think
why was tom riddle able to stare
directly into the basilisks eyes in the
chamber of secrets
is this a book to film blunder or did he
actually possess the ability
to look it dead in the eyes if he could
stare at it
how was it possible let me know in the
comment section below
until next time it does not do to dwell
on dreams
and forget to live
[Music]
you